generally the movie industry prefers
their authors did I mean they really
would prefer that I just not be there
they're very sweet about it everybody's
polite and pretends to be interested in
what I think but I had virtually no
input on the making of the blind side or
Moneyball know the movie industry I'm
pick up dancing shoe history book what
they have opinions about it my books
tend to hang on people and the people
are doing something really interesting
often disruptive changing industry I
would actually not be shocked if that it
got made into a movie I think that once
the story is digested and understood and
the sort of ramifications of it it could
really work who would play Brad you know
how can unfortunately the movie business
has a history of taking Asian heroes and
turning them into white guys so Brad
Pitt about Brad Pitt I only write about
things that really really interest me
and I think they're important and true
and I do it sincerely so I just assumed
some of that rubs off on the reader
you